16 fluid ounces plus three pints plus
four quarts is equal to how many gallons
now the one unfamiliar thing here that
we haven't seen before is this 16 fluid
ounces we've seen ounces before but not
fluid ounces and to make things
confusing they are actually very
different things fluid ounces fluid
ounces are a measure of volume fluid
ounces measure volume just like cups and
pints and quarts and gallons do while
ounces while ounces measure weight
measure weight and this might make it
kind of confusing or maybe less
confusing it also happens that a fluid
ounce of water at standard temperature
and pressure is going to weigh a little
bit more than an actual ounce so that's
why they're kind of close so a fluid
ounce of water is not that different in
weight than an ounce but there are two
fundamentally different things this is
volume this is weight now a fluid ounce
there's many ways you could think of
this one is that you have eight let me
write it here you have eight fluid
ounces fluid ounces per cup or since
there are two cups per pint
you also have sixteen fluid fluid ounces
16 fluid ounces per pint you could view
it either way
or you could say that you have 32 fluid
ounces per quart or you can multiply
that times 4 and that's how many fluid
ounces you have per gallons ounces which
is a unit of weight you have 16 ounces
16 ounces per pound and since I told you
that a fluid ounce is a little bit more
than an ounce you could kind of figure
out that hey a pint of water at standard
temperature and pressure and all of that
that a pint of water will weigh a little
bit more almost a pound or actually a
little bit more than a pound but roughly
equal to a pound so that's something
that might give you make things simpler
or more difficult now let's actually
tackle the problem so we have 16 fluid
ounces I just told you that there are 16
fluid ounces per pint so
16 fluid ounces let me write it over
here so 16 fluid fluid ounces fluid
ounces x times now we want the fluid
ounces to cancel out so we want fluid
ounces in the denominator times fluid
ounces fluid ounces
now how many fluid ounces are there per
pint we want a pint in the numerator so
that this and this cancel out well we
just saw that there are 16 fluid ounces
per pint or that 1/16 of a pint per
fluid ounce either way but we see this
and this will cancel out and so 16 over
16 is 16 times 1 divided by 16 is equal
to 1 pint now we know that 16 fluid
ounces is equal to a pint if we have 16
fluid ounces right over here this is 1
this is 1 pint right over there so we
have 1 pint plus another 3 pints so if
we were to add all of this part right
here together if we were to add all of
that together 1 pint plus 3 pints is 4
pints 4 pints now we have 4 pints let's
convert it to quarts 4 pints now we know
that there are 2 pints per quart or we
could view this we want the pints to
cancel out or 1 quart one quart is 2
pints or 1/2 quart per pint and we wrote
it this way instead of 2 over 1 is
because we wanted the quartz in the
numerator and the pints in the
denominator so that that and that cancel
out and it makes sense if you're
converting a smaller unit to a larger
you're going to have fewer of them so
you're essentially dividing by 2 so 4
times 1/2 or 4 divided by 2 is equal to
2 2 quarts so this whole piece right
here these 4 pints are equal to 2 quarts
that's 2 quarts and you could visualize
it you have to two of these combined
make one quarts you have 4 of them is
going to be 2 quarts so you have two
quarts here plus another 4 quarts so
this entire quantity if 2 quarts plus
this 4 quarts they are going to be 6 6
quarts so the entire quantity is 6
quarts and we have to convert that to
gallons so let me
right here we have six six quarts and we
want to convert it to gallons so we want
gallons in the numerator gallons and we
want quarts in the denominator so that
it cancels out with this Court's when we
multiply them and how many quarts are
there in a gallon or one gallon is 4
quarts 1 gallon is 4 quarts or 1/4 of a
gallon per quart now we can multiply the
courts cancel out you have 6 times 1/4
which is 6 over 4 gallons and now we can
simplify this we can divide the
numerator and the denominator by 2 this
is the same thing as 3 halfs gallons so
3 halves would be an acceptable answer
right here this would be 3 halfs gallons
if you want to write it as a mixed
number 3 divided by 2 is 1 with a
remainder 1 so it's 1 and 1/2 gallons
either one would be an acceptable answer